yes no I
okay hello how are you doing good to see
you could see you could see undreamed
annek that itch Wow huh how
whoa quality petite
let's get these qualities up framerate
that's slow as low slow
this is siren head and this one looks
pretty damn good for how quickly they
must have made it can never start a
horror game with like a happy note so
school is over and my friends want me to
go camping with them of course great
idea I don't really like camping but you
know my friends said hey Freddy you
never hang out with us you're always at
home playing Atari well I did just get
my driver's license may as well go and
have some fun hey it's the first day of
summer South Point Meadows here I come
I'm not gonna regret this me and my
friends we're gonna be able to see each
other in school again once we get back
from camping in the woods where there's
nothing evil park ranger guide you can
either protect your friends or save your
hose yeah essential part of the park
ranger handbook leave your friends in
the dust
welcome to South Point Meadows it's dark
out here you can use f to use your
flashlight and E to interact with
objects don't shine your flashlight too
long it could irritate people or some
things also use R to ping your next
objective if you get lost
I got it
Southpoint meadows okay Wow sure wish my
eyes had better resolutions too much
Atari whoa zoom all that time spent
staring at a CRT monitor really did a
number to my corneas oh hello hello I'm
more worried that it stopped hey buds hi
friends of mine you literally couldn't
have picked up scarier forest what trees
are the bees I thought it was summer I
didn't the dead of winter no leaves what
is it it's a pile of sticks all's good
in this neighborhood stuck on a tree
good where's the moon I see light but no
moon little straight all right this is
delightful this is so good I'm so happy
I'm not at home playing my Atari oh is
that our campsite hey best buds friends
of mine let's eat some grow
well I don't like that I don't like that
at all so all my friends are dead is
what I'm gathering from this information
that you have delivered to me all my
friends are dead and I'm alone in the
woods with a siren head after my giblets
that's the information I have gleaned
from the contextual Clues that you have
left me I am a big brand and consolidate
our think I might be in trouble
that is the second conclusion I'm making
from the data you have provided for me
[Music]
at least the wolves are thriving oh I
can run oh good you know I'll save it
why would I run Sallah anything's
chasing me
[Music]
what is it
at what point is the demonic chanting
normal can summon um how would I stay
right here how about I don't go either
of these directions thou such a variety
of noise
[Music]
such a diversity of noises I don't know
what god I hope I'm not walking into a
trap
I'd be unfortunate
[Music]
okay Oh No
okay maybe it's just noises it might
just be noises and there's actually
nothing that's fine that's a badger
that's clearly the mating call of a
wombat these are normal forest sounds
red
[Music]
that's a honeybee it's nothing to be
worried about nothing harmless harmless
little thing it's more afraid of me than
I am of it all right so far so nothing
tried to keep me on my toes my toes iwo
Zee yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah did I
see something in the woods here ooh what
is this hello
did I go in a big circle no this is
different
interesting this is like a campground
okay so so what about this I don't know
what I'm supposed to do said something
about holding our two ping there's no
pings
I don't have any objectives I don't know
what
[Music]
hello hmm oh that can't be good unless
it's very good right now I'm gonna go
this way or unless I'm supposed to go
towards the sound I don't know I got
back to a road finally I don't know
which way I'm going
[Music]
Oh rumbly tumbly rumbly bumbly tumbly
okay I think I went back to the fork in
the road that I found earlier ooh
this is a clearing power lines kind of
my guidance ooh there's watchtower over
there that'll definitely be good I'll
definitely be able to be safe there
I can't wait for this let me up there I
could use a nap sounds of demons
haunting in the woods hatch nothing
that's a easy-peasy form easy hello ooh
equip the rifle press 2 on the keyboard
put it away keeping the mind that you
can only hold one atom at a time rapid
didn't work what did it press 2 I'm
pressing to you too don't know how to
hold this rifle oh I have to put
who wants to get shot I don't know about
looking down the scope apparently who
wants to get shot
give me a siren head to murder I feel a
lot more confident now that I got a gun
so let's see what you got siren hood
more like siren nerd am i right
everybody okay there's the campsite I'm
just gonna keep following the road it's
gonna follow hey I could have barely
hold two things at once
well you know maybe the smart me would
Oh what I have a ping I actually have a
ping god damn it I actually have a god
damn and I do have a ping Oh was it the
tongue did I miss something in the tower
god damn it I did didn't I god damn it
fine okay sure
okay hey so if I'm up here what do I do
was there like some kind of no my ping
is still up here
I must have bugged it somehow god damn
it
ah so now I have a ping I didn't have a
ping before a strange is that blah oh I
didn't find blood that's what it was
I didn't find the blood oh my god oh my
god
so what I had to do is I had to go back
because apparently I didn't find the
blood
therefore my whole experience was ruined
well my experience wasn't ruined but the
the game loop was broken so I got to go
back to the tower now I mean I'm going
to the tower for the first time can't
wait to see with a help I'm gonna go in
the park ranger crates me with open arms
and even more open in a vicious
yes games making a lot more sense now
that I'm not just wandering through the
woods surprised I didn't run into sire
Ned before Park Ranger Park Ranger Park
Ranger Park Ranger senpai oh man is
horrible that my friends they're dead
they're all dead blood everywhere
help oh oh not here looks like the radio
tower is down there should be a cellar
or underground generator somewhere okay
Parker it's kind of messed up that
you're broadcasting the death of my own
friend to me kinda messed up siren who'd
know nope no no no
oh I might have bullets to the beginning
to the begun Yin rings okay a fire up
the sirens baby got it I'm willing to
bet I'm willing to bet yeah so I'm
thinking that they're active now but I
don't know if they can get me up here
and I definitely need not waste all of
my bullets but I do need to get over to
that red so I think if I cut through the
woods that'd be better even though I
think I saw a park ranger safety warning
that maybe mayhaps that might not be the
best of ideas
[Applause]
nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope
nope nope no no no no no is it all about
[ __ ] loser
I'm suck
oh no no no I suck no no no no no no no
no no don't know you don't know where I
am there's no way that you know where I
am
how can you know where I am okay only
one bullet per I'm wasting bullets by
doing it multiple times I don't know how
many I have left oh I'm gonna die again
RNA I've shot five bullets now oh that
ain't good
oh that's not good okay I thought that
was no no no no no no I'm done oh my god
Sarah's at you I don't have time to
check if that was Sarah or not now I
just need to get back and call for help
oh yeah
[Music]
no one knows what Freddy did Sarah that
don't look like Sarah to me oh okay so I
got a bit of a problem I got a bit of a
problem and that problem is uh siruni
had just kind of sneak sneak sneak my
way I really really hope I have bullets
oh I hate this no no no no this also I
think me upgrading the graphics to
ultram kind of killed my my pom-pom
rinse like oh that's not good
[Music]
fine total all good baby all good baby
all good baby all good baby baby all
good we're baby all good baby all good
all babies are good we will be
dispatching officers as soon as we can
but as you know you can't cancel that
area very easy there's a give up Presi
to lay down okay you know I'm all right
I don't want to lay down I also got to
be careful not to accidentally lay down
also yeah I don't know if the the
framerate is been kicking at it this
whole time or if it's just recently and
kind of kicking at it but these games
sometimes oh oh the same games sometimes
do that and I don't know why I've got a
good computer and yet apparently that
don't matter
hey you're coming no matter
yeah that's right I'm running screw that
screw that screw that screw that so hard
screw it sword I have no idea how many
bolts I have i pulp - criminy Christmas
I have a bullet oh no no no all this too
soon
no that's too soon oh that's so too soon
oh that's so too soon oh no not like
this one bullet one bullet I'm running
I'm running I'm running and I'm going
what okay I thought it was coming after
me again okay I've got to be close I
think I've shot seven bullets maybe I
have eight I'm hoping I've got eight
eight would be great
oh oh oh not no no no no no please tell
me I have eight bullets please I just I
so need eight bullets here oh no please
eight bullets a bullet 8 bits a bit yes
a bullets huh okay here we go
goodbye goodbye goodbye goodbye goodbye
did that creature do this how the hell
am I supposed to get across now I don't
know
jump Hey
oh I'm sorry oh I'm sorry was I not
supposed to jump across the water was
that what I wasn't supposed to do cuz it
sure seemed like I was
oh I'm sorry and I have to start all the
way from them are you serious oh my god
are you [ __ ] serious
wait what wait what wait what wait what
what what what wait wait what what what
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what was
that about what were you doing out of
your cage was he doing out of his game
so early have I just like been lucky
this entire time did I go in like the
wrong direction and suddenly I was ahead
no it's right here why was it here I
don't know
that was weird this game is good and
scary but I don't like the starting over
at the beginning completely alright get
back to the tower go to the bridge find
it's broken get my butthole reamed
so far only one bullet used and pretty
quick about it it's been kind of nice
not gonna lie okay so I'm gonna get this
gun it to the bridge and then I don't
know where to go after that but damn
you're loud I guess you know in
retrospect jumping into the broken
pieces of the bridge probably not the
wisest decision however you gotta you
gotta appreciate my gusto I was scared
and you know I just I didn't hesitate I
never hesitate I don't do that that's
not the kind of person I am you know to
you you know to me and you know what I
mean I think you all know what I mean
okay did that creature how am I suppose
to get across now good question good
question think I remember seeing a
factory over there
yeah a factory yeah I'm gonna rebuild it
with the factory pieces yep yep Baroni
it's awfully quiet in these woods
doesn't seem to be a whole lot of
monster Oh factory this why is there why
would this be in the middle of the woods
why would this be in the middle of the
woods is the question but why don't and
so for the officer said this way I don't
know where is this way where am I
huh what is this what is this
weird okay this makes no sense Oh what
is this
there's just walls swamp nothing here
it's a wall forever decided to build a
factory in the woods wasn't thinking
about location I wasn't thinking about
logistics all right I seem to have
somehow voided siren at all the other so
this is great this is good this is good
stuff I like this a lot ooh interesting
almost free keep following this path my
gun my guns kind of gone what path I'm
in the wood I'm in the woods I am in the
woods what path hello uh-huh do tell No
[Music]
so that was siren ed new-and-improved
there were a couple things game breaking
things that I did that made the game a
bit more frustrating than it had to be I
get that however the respawn mechanic
being completely at the beginning a
little over burdening however that being
said the game was still very good it you
know it's not any different than a lot
of the things that you see in horror
games but the style the style is very
good and I love the style I think
there's a lot of potential for this
style and I think there's a lot of
potential to see this concept evolved a
bit with siren it I think siren ed is
just a very scary creature like the idea
of siren ed is this very I don't know
there's so much potential for the horror
there and I like it a lot so there's a
lot to be done with this so I did enjoy
this a lot so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
thought down in the comments below if
you want to see more siren ed I think
there are more siren head games to play
smaller ones maybe I'll do like a three
scary siren ed games but uh this will be
this for now so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always here's
siren ed coming at you right now
[Music]